my parents were from different worlds
and now is a product of the love that
never should have been skits unite our
worlds one day
a son of the land and the son of disease
my mother always knew you were special
you are part of something deeper you are
the bridge between land and sea
take your rightful place as king
[Music]
we're getting close now yeah what's the
what buying a thirst
there's no way Atlantis with this far in
there check this place out
[Music]
nothing of course it's not working it's
been sitting here collecting dust since
before the Sahara was a desert before
the Sahara was a desert you do your best
thinking when you're not thinking at all
right now hold still Hey
what are you doing we need water you're
the closest source
[Music]
sure I could've just peed on it
[Music]
in this Trident resides the power of
Atlantis
if you seek my power
journey beyond the edge of the world to
the hidden sea
in the wrong hands
it would bring destruction
but in her hands literally
it would unite all our kingdoms above
and below
what we've written it down first I
memorized it didn't you
oh yeah what are you say something
something Trident the Beast has awakened
the time has come
for Lantis to rise again
who the hell are you
[Music]
oh is awesome
the war is coming to the surface
you are not going to win this
ian's will die unless you help us
I'm no leader
knocking
[Music]
he's always had a king now I need
something more
but what could be greater than a king
[Music]
a hero